if you want to hear my theory about what
the heck is going on here why is this
jack-o'-lantern in the fish tank and
stick around to the end of this video
welcome back to things you missed
earlier this week we talked about the
trailer for the new Halloween movie if
you haven't seen that video click on
over here to check it out and in the
comments for that video you guys had
some excellent points that I didn't
touch on in the first video in the
original Halloween the first guy Michael
kills in 1978 is this mechanic than
Phelps garage dr. Loomis finds the
hospital gown in the bushes and we pull
out to see this guy has been killed his
corpses in the bushes and his clothes
have been taken so that's how Michael
got his iconic garb face stabber 51
brought this up in the comments and it
made me realize something about the new
trailer where we see the same taking
place at an Auto Service Center the
British guy goes in and finds a body in
a puddle of blood he appears to be the
mechanic and he's in his underwear not
only is this paying tribute to John
Carpenter's Halloween but it tells us
that Michael seems to be retracing his
steps from all those years ago that
brings me to another comment which
theorizes that michael's rampage in old
halloween was never about going after
laurie but rather reliving the night
when he killed his sister Judith and I
agree and disagree with this he does
seem to be targeting Laurie ever since
he sees her drop off the key at the
Meijer house for her father who's a
realtor he's trying to sell the house
but he can't because everyone in town
thinks that it's haunted and let's face
it it kind of looks like but from that
point he's watching her in school
following her around town and turning up
at the house she babysits that night the
part I do agree with which is a great
point is the idea that Michael tries to
recreate the circumstances of Judith's
murder when he kills Annie both start
with him seeing the victim undressed
from outside he kills both with the
knife and then moves Annie to the bed
under Judith's tombstone to complete his
recreation so my point is if 1978 was
Michael Myers recreation of 1963 then
maybe 2018 is a recreation of 1978
starting with him killing the mechanic
for his clothes stealing the mask and
doing the go sheet thing and this time
trying not to let Laurie Strode
get away we don't know how Michael gets
his mask back in this movie or even if
it's the very same mask at all but a
couple of you theorized that he gets his
old mask back from this guy some of you
think he's the new head psychiatrist at
Smith's Cove and some say he's even
related to dr. Loomis while others say
that he's just a documentarian but many
of you noticed if you pause right here
it's actually his head being bashed into
the bathroom stall door so Michael
probably takes him out to steal back the
mask and maybe this location is Phelps
garage which is only referenced on the
side of this truck and the first one in
the last video I said that the bathroom
scene was a callback to h2o where the
woman gets attacked but Joshua Wilson
brings up a good point he never actually
attacked her he just scared her and
stole her car someone else brought up
another possible h2o reference that
being a waste time shot of Michael doing
this little knife flip move I'm not sure
if that's exclusive to h2o and I'm not
about to rewatch them all to find out
I'll just take your word for it it's a
nice little find okay I love this next
one suggested by low-budget skits in
this clip were Lauri yells at the
trick-or-treaters they get inside
there's a quick glimpse of two kids
running away wearing silver shamrock
masks from Halloween three season of the
witch if you haven't seen it the master
a major plot point of Halloween 3 so
this is a really cool split second
reference moving on I had previously
said that I thought this photo could be
Tommy Doyle and many of you thought it
was a young Michael Myers those of you
who said that were correct and here's
why
the file is probably Michaels file at
Smith's Cove where he was a patient
starting at age six this white wall
looks more like something out of a
sanitarium not a house the kid in the
photo has shorts on which Tommy does not
at the end of Halloween Michael is
initially taking him in while he's
wearing this clown costume so there's a
good chance that he had shorts on
underneath another correction you guys
made was on this diagram for some reason
I read this as one slash across the neck
and one on the shoulder but looking at
it again it's clearly one slash that
stretches the neck and shoulder plus I
looked back and Lori never actually gets
a cut on her neck so this is an injury
report for Annie not Lori and he gets
strangled and gets her throat slit in
the car when she's about to go pick up
her boyfriend and we can see the results
of her injuries later after Michael
relocates her to the bed
John Archangel wants to know do you
think Lori finally got with a Ben tramer
and if you don't remember Ben tramer is
the guy that Lori has a crush on who's
mentioned but not seen in the first
movie trailer Ben tramer
I know it and killed off early in
Halloween too but Halloween too doesn't
exist in this continuity so there's a
chance that they got together and Laurie
does have grandkids now
so I mean you never know I hope for her
sake that it works out between Laurie
and Ben in this continuity because they
just haven't had any luck in any of the
others plus it would be a cool throwaway
line if somebody mentioned that her
husband's name was Ben or something like
that the most mysterious part of the
trailer is this jack-o'-lantern inside
the fish tank I don't think it's a
Halloween decoration for the fishes I
actually have a theory on it I think
this guy in the foreground is actually
this guy the cop so he's coming to this
house to investigate a disturbance the
chairs been tipped over and there's
blood on the floor the sheet ghost isn't
moving either it's Michael Myers hiding
underneath or a victim's body that's
been covered up whatever the case may be
I think somebody tried to throw the
pumpkin at Michael in self-defense and
it missed and just ended up landing in
the fish tank but what do you think do
you think this is Michael do you think
it's one of the victims do you think
this guy at the end of the trailer is
the real Michael or just somebody
pulling a prank let me know in the
comments and if you've been enjoying all
the new videos lately let me know by
giving this one a like there's a lot
more to talk about so let's keep this
discussion going and make sure you're
subscribed to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive